Hello. Hello. Hello.
Hello.
Hey, Dan. How's it going?
It's going very well at the moment. I
I will start off by apologizing to the
fact that I appear to be a circle
that
pulses as I speak. My machine is so
unstable at the moment that
webcams cause it to power cycle at the
moment.
Because computers.
Yes. Maybe I'll I could do this this
minor inconvenience,
and we will just respect the
the circle, I guess.
Plus, we're not here to see your face.
We're here to see your code and your
demonstration.
Fear not. Excellent. So
today,
we're gonna take a look at one of
your open source project.
It's called kube VIP.
So why don't you just give a quick
thirty seconds intro about yourself and the project,
and then we'll take it from there.
Sure. So,
yeah, I've I've been kind of involved
a little bit in writing kind of software
around bare metal for a little bit of
time now.
It mainly stemmed from a customer that we
had when I was based in Hep Heptio.
Traveled all the way to go see this
customer in The Middle East, and I was
basically left to my own devices
in that
these people this customer was like, we want
a Kubernetes cluster on bare metal,
and we'll see you at the end of
the week,
which was nice. So I I kind of,
you know, I spent the week writing
a load of bash scripts to kind of
automate the process and,
you know, kind of the few things that
they specified was they wanted it as cloud
like as possible.
And,
you know, I kind of did with the
best that I could within that that one
week and kind of handed over to them
this this cluster all running on
a bunch of Dell machines.
But, you know, it's kinda quite clear that
I'd handed something over to them that they
still really weren't gonna be able to use
once I'd left.
But, you know, I kind of carried on
working with them a little bit after that.
And the more customers that I kind of
worked with that were looking kinda doing more
and more bare metal
deployments,
the more I kind of realized that there
was kind of quite a sizable hole in
terms of
what there was in the ecosystem in order
to kind of just do the deployment.
And then as we as I looked at
kind of trying to automate that and scale
those sorts of things up,
dealing with the load balancing part in front
of the in front of your control plane
started to annoy me in terms of what
was out there at the moment.
So I ended up
fiddling as I, I guess, I often do
and kind of coming up with
few ideas and how I could kind of
make things a bit easier,
especially in kind of conjunction things like cluster
API, which Jason was talking about
last week.
And that's kind of led me to where
I am at the moment.
Wow.
Interesting. Really, really interesting. So this
project is part of
I'm still laughing at clouds like Kubernetes,
but I'm gonna come back to that later.
That's that's the QVIP project is is part
of something broader called Plunder app. Do you
wanna just cover that as well?
Yeah. Sure. So
Plunder is
essentially a a bare metal provisioning tool.
So it's it's effectively
a a wrapper or or a load of
code around a bunch of, like, super old
technologies.
So, like, mainly
DHCP,
TFTP,
and HTTP, which are all
20 or 30 years old and are kinda
quite hard to manage
from a a static point of view. A
lot of configuration files and things like that.
So the main goal around all of this
was to basically put an API on top
of all of this,
and that is effectively what Plunder does. It
it it provides an API
on top of
DHCP and TFTP.
And it it it actually
has all of those technologies built in. So
even though it's a single binary, it runs
as, like, three or four different servers.
And then exposes all of those in a
way that we can I can kind of
automate
and actually do then bare metal provisioning?
So that's
again, you know, I had an itch and
this is kind of the the scratch to
that itch, I suppose, on on bare metal
provisioning.
Yeah. I mean, tackling these kind of problems.
I mean, would you say you have masochistic
tendencies?
Well, so,
I mean, I I I did a talk
about this at one of the Go
meetups not so long ago where I had
to apologize. Well, I I felt that I
should apologize because
I was developing a lot of this whilst
I was kind of, you know, working with
customers. And at one point, I was in
a a hotel in Germany,
and I've been developing this
on my laptop with a bunch of VMs
and things. And I left my laptop kinda
connected to the network. And when I came
back from dinner,
I noticed that one of the wall computers
that they had, which advertised what was taking
place in one of the conference rooms,
actually had a Linux prompt being displayed on
it.
It turned out that all of those machines
would DHCP
boot on the same network as the Wi
Fi.
And I've been basically giving out leases to
various machines around the hotel which should start
provisioning themselves from Plunder.
So they
yeah. I mean, it's it's dangerous technology
in the wrong hands, I suppose.
Please never work on this project when you're
on a plane, at least if I'm on
it, for sure. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So
we're gonna take a look at is it
kube kube-vet or kube-vip?
I I've called it kube-vip,
but, I mean, it it's I I mean,
I have no there's no kube cuddle, kube
control
arguments here on on that one. Well, that's
a cloud native way. Like, we have to
we have to argue or debate the semantics
of the pronunciation. So I'm gonna say kube-vip.
You can continue to say vet, then we'll
let other people make their own team or
decisions. No problem.
So let's let's look at the
the GitHub page here. So it's a Kubernetes
control plane, virtual IP, and load balancer. So
what makes bare metal different from, you know,
maybe Kubernetes customers that people are used to
running on AWS, GCP, etcetera?
The biggest thing that's kind of missing is
the out of the box
IP address and kind of load balancer.
So
with AWS
or
Azure, etcetera,
all of the bits that you kind of
need to have
another IP address that that can move around
or you'd be used to point at a
different member of the control plane is is
already exists.
When we look at bare metal,
a lot of those technologies you have to
implement yourself
and manage them yourself as well.
So Are we using something like KeepAliveD?
Is that Yes. Is that doing something similar,
like, is responsibility school? It is. Yes. So
KeepAliveD,
there there are a couple of others I
think I mentioned at the bottom
on there.
They do work in the in in a
similar manner and that you would have a
keep alive cluster as such.
And that would do some level of
voting or whatever cluster management
and move an IP address around.
The problem that I kind of found there
is that I would then need to have
to manage
an an extra cluster,
a keep alive cluster,
and the configuration
that goes within
so you keepalive.conf
and things like that. Ideally, I wanted something
that was slightly
easier to manage.
And I suppose to a certain degree, something
that was a bit more tightly coupled to
Kubernetes.
Nice.
Okay.
So I believe
that you
are
boldly gonna attempt to show us
this project in action in two different ways.
Right? Do wanna cover what those are gonna
be? Sure. Yes. So
the original
plan for for
kube-vip or whatever kind of wasn't its first
guide was really just
to be able to have basically a fourth
IP address or or an IP address that
I would hit,
and then I would go to one of
the control plane members underneath.
And then
as as often happens, I was like, oh,
I've always wanted to work out how to
write a load balancer inside Kubernetes, so service
type load balancer,
which is
a rabbit hole to a certain degree and
and having to do various other things. But,
you know, I kind of I quite happily
I was very surprised even when I I
finally managed to get that to work. So
kube-vip is
not only a
a virtual IP and load balancer that sits
in front of the control plane, but you
can also deploy it within
within Kubernetes
and then use that as a load balancer
for, you know, for deployment or for for
pods and things like that.
Okay.
You're just setting out with loads of sentences
today that I never thought I'd hear anyone
in my life say that
I want to know how to write a
service load balancer for Kubernetes. Like, surely, less
than three people in the world have ever
uttered those words.
No. I actually I mean, I I luckily
managed to find a load of work by,
like, people like James Mondly,
who'd kind of had to play with it
years ago and and whatnot. And whilst
the way that you write controllers has changed
and, you know, there's a lot of kind
of frameworks around there and things like that,
I I the docs still do suffer a
little bit. You are kind of left in
the dark in terms of
why do I need to implement this and
how does it work. But
I did struggle for quite some time, but
I was kind of, like, you know, kinda
quite happy that I did actually manage to
work out what was going on towards the
end.
Nice. So I'm looking forward to seeing it.
So what I'm gonna do now is I'm
gonna pop your screen.
Wichita.
Yep. And it is now being shared.
So I can see
three terminals.
So what's going on here?
So we have three
three bare metal nodes that are
running on packet. And
so they're they're all up and running.
The only things that have happened to these
is they're running basically Ubuntu 18 o four.
I've
done an app to get install of
the various packages that are required.
So we can now basically initialize a a
Kubernetes cluster in a in a manner.
So one thing I will do is I'm
just gonna quickly pop open one more terminal
and make that a little bit bigger.
Right. Okay. So what we're gonna do on
on the on the bigger pane, this one
here, is we will go through the two
steps
that are needed in order to initialize our
first control plane node.
And
the method around this is kind of a
bit important. A lot of this is tied
to kube a d m.
I know there are multiple different ways of
initializing a Kubernetes cluster.
I've
always been kind of in the q a
d m camp, I suppose.
This always seemed like kind of the and
given its kind of popularity and how you
use that with cluster API,
it made sense for me at least to
follow that method. There are a number of
different ways that you could perhaps instantiate
the the Vip side of things, but, yeah,
I'll step through that.
So
okay.
So on our first node, the first thing
that we're going to do
is to do a docker run.
Oh, crap.
I don't know how best one second. I
will need to do something.
I'll move this window over here a second
so that I can take my key out
of the history.
It's always the way, isn't it? Yeah. It's
pretty
I just moved the window. Nothing to see
here. I'll come back and choose the moment.
I lost track of the amount of times
I've put access keys or tokens onto Yes.
Yeah.
So
one second.
If anyone has any questions about kube-vip,
plunder, packet, anything like that, just feel free
to drop them into the chat on YouTube,
Periscope, Twitter, or Twitch.
Cool. We will do our best to answer.
So if we can pretend we didn't see
that,
what's actually happening here is that we're gonna
do a docker run using the kube vip
image.
And
passing it a number of flags. So there's
a number of kind of key important ones
really here.
The main one really is we're we're gonna
be using BGP
and we're gonna be binding to an internal
interface and and whatnot. But the main thing
here is that we're actually gonna be using
kube-vip to generate a static pod manifest.
So the reason why we're doing this really
has been kind of a lot of work
that's kind of get around the chicken and
egg problem
of running a VIP and load balancer inside
a Kubernetes cluster.
Now, the reason why this is a chicken
and egg problem is that of the way
that kube-adm
init actually works.
So I'll generate this manifest and we'll kick
off the kube-adm init.
And, we'll leave this pinging. So, what's actually
the the chicken and egg scenario here is
essentially the
kube-adm in it.
If we want to use a control plane,
we need to give it the IP address
of the control plane
the load balance that that we're wanting to
make use of.
Now, if we are in AWS or we
have an appliance like an f five load
balancer,
that device already exists or we can build
that functionality before we actually
build up our Kubernetes cluster.
So we can see here we have successfully
deployed the first node.
And on the right hand window, we can
now see that our EIP exists
to actually access. So
kind of coming back to that chicken and
egg scenario,
we need a way of bringing up the
load balancer kind of at the same time
that we bring up the Kubernetes cluster
because kube-adm
in it will start all of the manifests
that exist within
the manifests directory.
Once it has basically told kubelet to start
all of those,
the kube-adm init's kind of final steps are
to
to basically
check that control plane endpoint
and
basically do a a get on health to
make sure that things are up and running
as expected.
So we will add now in our additional
nodes as you would do.
Okay. So this is just the other two
other bare metal machines which are now joining
the cluster.
So this will take a few seconds also.
But
there's another thing that we have to be
aware of here. So we can generate the
manifest
first
when we do a kube a d m
in it.
However, a kube a d m join
will error if that static pod manifest exists
on join. So the manifest directory has to
be empty on a join,
but it can be pre populated on an
in it, which
I don't know. I mean, I'm waving my
hands in the air, but my camera's not
on, so
such is life.
So the final step really on the first
node, we generate the static pod manifest. Kube
adm init will then bring up all of
the static pod manifests in that directory, including
the kube vip manifest.
So as everything all comes up, our vip
is initiated
and is substantiated.
Kube a d m in it can speak
through that vip to the control plane, and
we now have that up and running.
On the additional nodes, we join them using
the normal kube ADM join.
The last step here
One second.
If we do the same docker run command,
that will generate the same static pod manifest
into the etcd manifest Kubernetes manifest directory.
And now kube-vip will be running
on all three of the control plane nodes
as a static pod manifest.
And the way that kube-vip works is that
it uses
the Kubernetes
scheduler
leader election.
So if I grab our token here,
we can kind of see this in action,
which is
so we can see our
three
kube-vip pods that are actually running. And if
we
we can see here
that we have the lock and we have
assumed leadership of the cluster.
And we're also using BGP
to inform
the routers that that exist within the packet
network.
The traffic for our external IP address should
come to this node.
Now this is important because
we're gonna kill the first node.
And we should see on the window on
the right, we will lose a few packets
as
a leader election will take place in the
cluster, and our EIP will move to one
of the other nodes in that cluster.
So three, two, one.
Sounds ambitious.
Oh.
Boom.
So That was fast.
Yeah. It it so it turns out we
can actually do it faster than that.
I've just not had the chance this weekend
to implement that functionality,
but
I'm still learning a lot about BGP.
It's a bit of a terrifying
technology.
There was another major outage this weekend
that took place. And when I was implementing
this for the first time inside the
inside the packet network,
I actually had to ask a number of
network engineers
to sit and monitor the switches for the
first time I actually did a failover
to make sure I didn't break anything inside
the packs. The last thing I wanna do
is start breaking bits of the Internet and
whatnot. But it's a You were responsible for
the CenturyLink outage. Is that what you're saying?
Luckily, I don't think it was me, but
there was a Zoom outage when I actually
tried this the first time. But I don't
think I had anything to do with that.
But, yeah, it it's a it is a
bit of a terrifying technology. But
it turns out in inside the packet now,
we have a lot of safeguards in place
to prevent people doing anything
anything kind of too silly with with BGP.
Yeah. So so just for the, you know,
the people that are watching. Right? That the
high level of BGP is if you
can speak to the router and say, want
to register myself as
the responder
for this IP address or prefix, and then
that router will send direct all the traffic
that looking for that IP address or prefix
to your machine. Is that Yep. Okay.
Yep. So
yes. Well done. That's better than I could
have explained it, actually.
Yeah. So, I I mean, effectively,
what's actually happening is when one of the
kube-vip nodes gets the leader election and and
is given the leader lease,
that that particular pod will then start advertising
an IP address in a number of different
ways.
Within packet or using just BGP generally,
we will need to give it the peering
details for a router in that network.
So it can connect to that network and
say
traffic that wants to hit this particular IP
address should be routed through me. I'm the
leader.
Alternatively,
in a a layer two manner,
we can use ARP. So I it's disabled
inside here because it it simply just won't
work
because it's blocked within packet.
But on a different network,
what would happen on leader election is that
a a node that is allocated the leader
lease will suddenly do an ARP broadcast to
switches and
network devices,
which says that
if you want to this IP address, which
is our VIP, is accessible on this MAC
address,
which is the MAC address of the host
that now has a leader election. So that's
layer two updates, which says where traffic should
actually go.
Okay.
Cool.
Well, you get into the weeds in networking
here. It's been a it's been a learning
experience for for me as well.
So just to clarify then, this is this
is very much a bare metal problem. Right?
This is not something you would experience on
GCP or AWS because of all the virtualization,
and there's just something there
reconfiguring
the network and all the VMs. Right? This
is but on bare metal, we we don't
have that flexibility. And that's why this is
needed. Is that correct?
Yes. Within
within, you know, kind of Azure and AWS,
a lot of this functionality
is provided through software.
You won't you wouldn't need to implement any
of this yourself.
There
exists a myriad of services in all of
these cloud providers. So,
you know, you don't need to worry about
any of these sorts of things. A simple
API call to the AWS SDK
and, you know, your your elastic IP will
move anywhere it needs to go.
And one final thing. There's there's nothing packet
specific here. Right? This is using BGP, which
would work in any bare metal cluster with
a a root over there to handle the
request. Right? Yes. The so the only thing
that is packet specific, which is why I
accidentally
flashed my API key to the to the
world, I suppose,
is that
using that API key,
kube-vip can look up all of the BGP
configuration that we would normally have to specify
manually.
So
with the API token, kube-vip can actually look
up all of the pairing information
so that it knows who to give the
addresses to and things like that. So it
was it's just another kind of
ease easy easy step, well, for me at
least,
to skip out, you know, kind of having
to do things manually and whatnot.
Okay. They're right. This will work anywhere that
there are reasons that advertise on BGP.
Right.
So I think what we've covered there then
is the VIP aspect of kube
VIP.
And we have a and I should have
said that there just to kinda break that
up. But we
have a highly available Kubernetes control plane with
relative ease.
Yes. So I tried to make it follow
as much of the kube a d m
path steps, whatever you wanna call it, as
much as possible,
and to automate things as much as possible
as well. So
either dropping static pods
either dropping static manifests
into the manifest directory.
Another option is
doing
either kube a d m in it in
phases
or having a program that runs and watches
for
the API server coming up for the first
time and immediately dropping a daemon set
in there before the kube a d m
in it process finishes.
That daemon set comes up along with the
vip.
Kube a d m in it can hit
that vip and verify that the cluster's up
and running and things like that. It's very
hacky, but there's no real nice options at
the moment.
Could we not? I don't I don't wanna,
you know, go into this too much. It's
not really what we're trying to cover, but,
like, this feels like something system d could
solve using their triggers. Like, when this process
comes up, then go and, you know, write
this manifest as directory if it doesn't exist.
Yes.
Possibly.
I mean
so things like cluster API vSphere,
that will
they've added now some webhooks in there, I
think, which will generate just static manifest
YAML
as part of the deployment of new cluster
API vSphere VMs. So they've actually taken the
instantiation part and added that into
their provider themselves.
So there are a number of different ways
to do it. It's just
kube-vip needs to come up before kube-adm init
finishes.
But Kubernetes
isn't up before
kube- ADM and it starts and things like
that. So you need to find your way
into the middle of the process one way
or another.
Right. Okay. That sounds too complicated. I'm gonna
just pretend and say, cool. Yeah. Good luck
fixing that. So
let's talk about the second part of give
that plan. Okay.
As as a load balancer. Right?
Yes. So
this largely works in the same way. So
these are gonna be a little bit hard
to see. We really, really need to focus
on the main window here.
I have a a five node cluster
that's up and running
with
two control
two
two worker nodes and and three control plane
nodes. They've been brought up in the same
same way. The only real difference here is
these machines aren't on packet.
So
the control play notes are simply using ARP
for that. However,
the main part that we're gonna be looking
at really is deploying an application
and then using kube-vip to advertise
it in the same manner. So
relatively straightforward.
I shouldn't have to use my own code,
but I'm actually having to get the docs
up at this point.
So if you go to kubevip.io
actually, I can pop it here, I think.
If we actually go to the main website
itself
Nice logo. We got to judge every project
by its logo. Absolutely.
So there is documentation for either doing the
control plane load balancer, which as I mentioned
is
one additional step to kube-eighty m in it.
And then actually doing a a Kubernetes service
type load balancer.
The load balancer part is a little bit
more involved
in that
we need to deploy a couple of manifests.
And the reason being
is,
I guess, there's a few things that we
need to kind of consider when doing service
type load balancer.
The main part really is the fact that
we we basically need a a CCM, cloud
controller,
Because the cloud controller
is the component inside the Kubernetes cluster that
will sit and listen
for things like service type load balances. And
it's the cloud controller
which would speak to something in order to
actually set that load balancer
up.
So for instance, in AWS,
the CCM
will more than likely speak to,
you know, your elastic IP service,
provision that elastic IP,
you know, kind of do all of the
plumbing
to bring that traffic back into your Kubernetes
cluster and whatnot. We need to do the
same with kube-vip.
So
what I'm gonna do though so these are
the two manifests that actually
will just get you running out of the
box.
I've actually been working on some additional functionality
which may break
probably will break.
Controller DHCP.
So this is some this is a suggestion
by
a colleague when I was at VMware
who wanted
to be able to do service type load
balancer,
but for, like, home networks
where they didn't really want to have to
worry about managing their own IPs and and
whatnot.
So this will we'll go through the normal
steps, then hopefully, we'll be able to demo
this as well.
But what we've actually done here is we've
created
we've we've applied two manifests.
The first manifest will deploy the
plunder cloud provider.
So this now will
take this cluster. And when
somebody wants to deploy
a service type load balancer, that cloud controller
will basically handle
all of the bits that are actually required
to do that.
The second manifest is the manifest that deploys
kube-vip
within
within a cluster itself.
And the architecture for this is
a little bit funny. I've got a diagram
of it somewhere.
Here we go. I don't know if this
will be visible or not.
But the way that it kind of works
is that you typically will deploy a kube
vip cluster
inside
a
a namespace.
What this allows you to do is to
specify
a side arrange for that namespace.
A file option?
Oh. No. It's not here. I'm just I'm
just reading this diagram and
Okay. So, basically, this allows us to use
a different network range
for each namespace.
It it it also allows us to kind
of have segregation
based upon network configuration
in a particular namespace as well.
In the deployment that we've done here, we've
just deployed kube-vip in the default namespace.
We should be able to see this.
So
what's also happening here is
the
I I I can't remember why I did
this, but the the manifest for kube-vip
will always attempt to deploy
three instances at least.
But I've only got two nodes here, and
there was logic in the manifest to stop
to
kube-vip instances sitting on the same node. That's
why we have a a a one that's
left in pending. If I were to add
an extra node an extra worker, then it
would just deploy on that that additional worker.
So
we've got kube-vip up and running. What we
will do now is
we will
let shrink it down a little bit.
Do something quite obvious. We will
we'll deploy we'll create a quick deployment.
So we're doing an NGINX deployment,
which shouldn't take long to come up.
And finally,
let me just check the namespace.
So one of the other ways that this
works as well
is
it uses a
config map in the cube system namespace, which
is where
the cloud controller lives.
So that whoever is admin of the cluster
defines
the network ranges that kube-vip can run-in a
particular namespace.
We can see
here.
So
the way that it works is the network
range space and then the namespace.
So in the default namespace,
if I were to do a expose of
service type load balancer,
this is the network range that those IP
addresses can actually come from.
So
in in this config map, you typically say
that
perhaps in my namespace finance,
they get a side arrange of these 10
IP addresses.
In
in my debug or development environment, they may
have a hundred IP addresses in this particular
subnet and things like that.
So the
final step so we we we have kube-vip
up and running.
So now you're gonna load balance those two
engine x pods. Right? Yes.
There we go. So what we're gonna do,
we will expose those
And there we go. What's happened here is
that the cloud provider
will have looked up
the
the range in the in the config map.
It will have found an available IP address.
So IPAM is also managed by the cloud
controller.
It
will find a free IP address. All of
them will have been free at this point,
but it will have then selected the first
IP address in that side arrange.
And it will then use that IP address.
Kube vip is told that that is the
vip
for the load balancer.
So it will then take care of using
up to broadcast
that whichever
is the leader vip instance
now has this IP address.
And if we hit this IP address,
we should go through to one of the
NGINX instances.
So
that has basically
used the same technologies that we talked about
earlier.
These are the layer two technologies to advertise
an internal IP address that the rest of
the network can access that will load balance
back to those instances underneath.
So some additional things I'm looking at are
adding BGP
into this part of it.
It's a little bit more complicated
in that we're not really gonna be in
charge of the IP ranges
in most places in most cases.
So we'll I'll need to have some logic
in there,
but it's
certainly doable. All of the code already exists.
And the other thing that I was hoping
to demonstrate,
if I can remember the
right
line for it,
is
because you mentioned some sort of DHCP
stuff. Right?
Or if that or is that already what's
happening with the this load balancer IP address?
No. The so the IP address that was
allocated, that 201,
that came from the
the cloud controller.
Here it is.
So this I can't this might work.
And let's give the name
dash DHCP.
Right.
What was done there? Nope.
I need to give it the
that's the name of the deployment. Our load
balance will be called dash d h c
p.
Right there also. Right. Okay. So what I've
done here
is we've specified
a load balancer IP
of 0000,
which obviously is a kind of a nonsensical
IP address.
And if I've gotten the right image downloaded,
was in a bit of a rush.
What will actually have happened
is that instead of the cloud provider
looking at the cider range and finding an
IP address that is available,
that the kube vip instance that was the
leader
will have actually done a DHCP request
from the network that it's on,
which the the idea behind this is kind
of edge environments where
we don't wanna worry about IPAM. We basically
may have a tiny Kubernetes cluster
that sits under a small router somewhere.
And we can basically just have the router
use DHCP leases
and apply those into our load balancer instance.
Nice.
Oh, it's not worked.
Maybe I've got the wrong pods downloaded.
If it had worked That'd be impressive.
Yeah. If it had worked, we would have
had the
the DHCP IP address here, not the 000.
Damn it. Live demos.
Okay.
That's okay.
I should give the script to figure it
out.
Oh, you're gonna try and fix it. Oh.
Live live debugging.
I've got the wrong interface.
It's ends 160,
and then my config is wrong.
Oh.
That's what's wrong. So it's it's basically
if my config had have been right,
what would have happened is that it would
have done a DHCP request on that interface,
and we wouldn't have had this issue.
If we have time, I can probably try
and fix it. If not, it's not really
the end of the world. It's a config
issue, not not my code
apparently.
But Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There we go. Excellent.
So yeah. That's
So that allows you to have kubernetes sorry.
I'm kinda talking over there. That allows you
to have services
which register themselves on the the the physical
network. Right? That's kind of what this is
doing. Yeah. Absolutely. That service would be available
to anything on my network whether it's part
of the Kubernetes cluster or not. Yes. Absolutely.
So
the the the person who came up with
this idea was,
yeah, just for for, like, home lab usage.
Instead of having to worry about,
you know, kind of coming up with IP
addresses and whatnot,
the the plan was that
DHCP
that already exists in the building of
from his ADSL router,
it basically, if I do an expose
and pass the IP address, then, you know,
my router will give me an IP address
on the network.
And I don't really have to care about
it. I'll just get the IP address to
get services.
And that router supplied IP address is my
load balancer IP address.
Very, very cool. I like it.
So I guess the
the big scary question I've got there is
everything you're showing so far is IPv four.
Run.
What's what's this the status of I p
v six? Is is
that's still applicable? Is this still something that
you want to support? Does this support you?
Or it doesn't support already?
I have not even tested
I p v six at this point.
As I mentioned, this is mainly been to
kind of scratch an
itch
internally, and I I don't really have any
I p v six
in my house
really to test this. And
the people that are starting to use this,
nobody has actually raised
a requirement for I p v six at
the moment.
However,
all of the things that it's actually doing,
there
shouldn't be any real reason why it would
be an issue to implement
I p v six support.
Okay. Maybe that's something I'll try and
okay. Maybe spin up a cluster. Is that
a hack and pack? We'll try to I
p v six only.
I think there is some some of the
Go API. Some of the Go calls are
maybe IPv four specific.
I can't remember off the top of my
head.
And for the BGP stuff, it is specifically
doing IPv
four
routes that it's adding.
So that definitely will would result in an
error
off the top of my head. But as
I mentioned, I don't see I don't see
why not. It's just not been done. That's
all.
Alright. That's
awesome. There is a lot to take in
there, but that is all very, very cool.
What's coming next?
What's next on the plunder head list? So
there's a couple of things that have been
suggested by a couple of colleagues
that are are basically kind of half implemented
and
should be coming in in next release.
One is UPnP.
So what that means is that if we
do a kube-ctl expose again, these are kind
of like home or edge networks and things
like that.
And we enable that.
The the ports that we specify as part
of the expose would also be specified on
your router.
So you could do a kube-ctl expose
port
one eighty eighty,
and your router would port forward immediately
to the kube-vip instance in your Kubernetes cluster.
So you could expose a service
at home to the Internet
using UPnP.
Okay.
And finally I'd I'd
I do. Does that that make sense?
Yeah. I think I'm just catching up with
you. I'm just I'm just thinking about it.
So yeah.
So it's it's basically normally, if you had
a service inside your house, you would need
to go to your router and enable port
forwarding.
But
the majority of home routers typically will support
UPNP,
which would allow us to basically broadcast
one of the whichever kube-vip instances leader will
broadcast
this port.
I wanna expose it via UPnP
back to myself,
and UPnP will take care of the port
forwarding automatically.
So a kube-ctl
expose
will automatically
tell your home router,
open this port on your firewall,
and incoming traffic on that port should also
come to this kube-vip instance.
So Ah, I get it. I get it.
Okay.
And what do you know? It just took
a bit longer than most.
A multicast DNS as well was something I
was thinking about implementing. So
we could expose a service and we would
m DNS it. So a bit like Bonjour
well, exactly like Bonjour services and things like
that.
A service would be advertised on the network.
Your load balance service will be advertised
through multicast
DNS.
Not entirely sure who or anybody would ever
use that, but
I don't know. I was I was coming
up with a bunch of random ideas one
night, that just seemed like something to implement
as well.
Alright. Random ideas are the best ideas. Yeah.
Absolutely. And then maybe IPv6.
So
Yeah. Definitely IPv6 because, you know, IPv4 is
we're done with that. Right? The whole world
is IPv6 now. That's what I hear.
So we got two comments. So Bradley said
sweet.
I think that was on the u m
p UPnP
stuff.
But he also asked a question.
And I think we're just jumping back maybe
five minutes now. But what he says is,
am I right in thinking that your router
would be able to handle a DHCP request
from the controller
and assign your machine another IP address?
So I guess this is the DHCP support
that he's referencing here. So
it it really does need a diagram because
it's a little bit hard to explain.
But what what would actually happen what should
have happened is
the
when you specify an expose and you want
to use DHCP,
kube-vip will basically run a DHCP server requesting
another IP address on the network.
It will create an additional interface
within the host that's the leader, and it
will bind
the
lease,
your DHCP IP address
to
to that additional interface. So
we have
your eth 0. You can have ETH 0
colon zero, ETH zero colon one. These are
additional stacks,
TCP stacks that live on the same physical
interface.
So we can broadcast from the physical interface
and then bind that configuration
to a kind of pseudo adapter,
which will take care of handling the traffic
and passing it back to kube-vip
and pass that then to the pods that
sit underneath.
So effectively,
you know, kind of the same way a
virtual machine would spin up a virtual Ethernet
adapter and do a DHCP request. We're kinda
doing something similar
with kube-vip, but we're basically just spinning up
a
it's a a Mac v tap that we're
actually using in order to do a layer
two. I want a DHCP address,
and it will then take care of assigning
that and doing what it needs to do.
Okay. I understood some of that. Wonderful.
Sorry. Have to.
Documentation is solely lacking, unfortunately.
Probably, I just asked one more question then.
He's asking, can you use zero conf? I
don't know what that is. For the DNS
multicast.
It's a good question. I I so
I mean, zero conf normally is
when something boots up for the first time,
it will do kind of some level of
request on the network for
configuration
information. So
some switches
will do zero confident. You turn them on
for the first time, and they will pull
their config from somewhere.
I'm not sure how that would. The the
idea for the the the I was looking
up for MDNS was basically
I would do an expose of my NGINX
and anything that uses
an MDNS looker would be able to find
that on the network, get its IP address,
and suddenly start speaking to it. So it's
it's
in my head, I was gonna use it
as another way of kind of service discovery.
Alright. Okay. Cool.
I think that handles all of our questions.
Do you have any closing thoughts that you'd
like to finish up?
No. Not so far. I'm
if anybody has any
suggestions or or things that
they would like to see implemented,
then
feel free. I'm always kind of looking for
new things to implement
and kind of fiddle with.
Yeah.
You know, it's out there. If you wanna
use it, go for it. If you've got
any feedback, I'd love to hear it.
Alright. Well, thank you very much, pulsing circle,
Dan. It's been an absolute pleasure. I have
learned a ton.
So thank you very much for joining me.
That was it was really cool. I enjoyed
that. Thank you. Alright. Have a nice day.
I'll speak to you all soon. Thanks. Bye.